I can hardly believe I'm here
My name is Terence McKenna and
my training is basically in shamanism and botany
and ethnography. Well until a few minutes ago I thought that this was a 45 minute gig, so...
you get to see grace under pressure this
evening
actually I'm kidding it doesn't matter
how long it goes
we could never get to the bottom of
this stuff
nor would we wish to, I think
you know one of the things that has
amazed me
with my own personal career
because you know I started out basically
shoveling snow
in a cowntown in Colorado and by
faith or who knows what
come to the present position
and what I notice as I
traverse levels on a supposed ladder of success
where you would expect
there to be more and more competition
and
people and activity.. actually it gets
emptier and emptier
there is nobody minding the store as far as I can tell
this is why I'm so unsympathetic
to conspiracy theory, we could use a few
conspiracies, nobody is minding the store
everybody is getting rich
personally rich
and so all this fantastic apparatus that we see around us is really
not so much in the service of channeling liquids,
gases,
but in the service channeling spirit
and into the higher realms where it then can be
refluxed, recondensed and the
lapis philosophorum
the stone of the philosophers, the central mystery, brought to completion
it is upon us
every messiah, every religious ontology,
every manager
of every booth at this exhibit
is reflecting a distorted scintilla
of the spiritual reality of the transcendental object at the end of time
everyone of us is a particularized
and distorted image of this
transcendental object, into which
we are being dissolved
so,
uh..
well, so what?